3d drucker haben in den letzten jahren
einen riesigen zuwachs an aufmerksamkeit
bekommen inzwischen kennt eigentlich
jeder das prinzip mit hilfe von
einzelnen dünnen schichten jedes
beliebige objekte dreidimensional
drucken zu können
doch eine komplett neue technologie die
erst vor wenigen wochen vorgestellt
wurde will die jetzt noch sehr junge
branche revolutionieren
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
what's on die noch sehr junge
technologie für 3d druckens wird ständig
verbessert und verändert dennoch gibt es
einige sehr näher für die nachteile wenn
man sich dazu entscheidet einen der
vielen 3d drucker auf dem markt zu
kaufen zum beispiel dort ist verdammt
lang ein objekt zu drucken
selbst bei kleineren objekten sollte man
von mehreren stunden ausgehen während
der drucker mehr oder weniger laute und
vor allem merkel die geräusche von sich
gibt
außerdem kann man den gegenständen die
gedruckt werden oft ansehen dass sie auf
diese weise hergestellt wurden wer schon
mal etwas von einem 3d drucker in der
hand gehalten hat der wird die vielen
kleinen rillen gesehen haben die von den
einzelnen lagen stangen übrigens sorgen
die einzelnen flächen auch dafür dass es
wichtig ist in welcher orientierung der
gegenstand gedruckt wird da entlang
dieser linien der gegenstand nicht so
widerstandsfähig ist und dort leichter
durchbrechen kann
doch jetzt kommt eine neue idee aus
hollywood auf den markt sowie der t 1000
oft terminal a 2 aus einer flüssigkeit
zu einem objekt wird so soll auch das so
genannte clipping funktionieren man
beginnt mit einer schale flüssigkeit
dann senkt sich eine plattform von oben
in die flüssigkeit hinein während ein
projekt doch von unten durch die schale
hindurch das gewünschte objekt
projiziert im ultravioletten bereich
wird die plattform dann angestrahlt und
sowohl lichtwellen als auch sauerstoff
erreichen die plattform und an genau
diesen stellen wird die flüssigkeit zu
einem festen objekt mit einer konstanten
geschwindigkeit bewegt sich diese
plattform dann nach oben und das 3d
objekt wird gebildet
auf diese weise kann man jetzt schon bis
zu 100 mal schneller drücken als mit
einem herkömmlichen 3d drucker die
gegenstände sind nicht nur wesentlich
stabiler
man kann auch mehr materialien als nur
plastik verwenden was einfach nur super
ist und man hat eine glatte oberfläche
und keine will
doch reicht das aus um den 3d drucker
auch in der zukunft an die
durchschnittlichen familien
verkaufen im moment sind 3d drucker
extrem geniale unterstützer auf
spezialgebieten wie zum beispiel der
medizin
mit ihnen kann man kostengünstige
individuelle prothesen und
hilfestellungen für tiere und menschen
drucken die nasa druck seit letztem jahr
ersatzteile für astronauten im weltall
und tüftler können bereits jetzt
komplette autos aus dem 3d drucker
herstellen und das herz in kombination
mit den eigenen stammzellen habe ich ja
sogar schon in der letzten folge
angesprochen
das ist ja alles mega cool aber das sind
ja auch alles sehr spezialisierte
aufgabenbereiche und ich persönlich
finde es schwerer mir vorzustellen wie
sich der durchschnittsbürger für mehrere
tausend euro so einen 3d drucker zulegen
sollte ich war in alltagsgegenstände die
jedermann braucht sind immer noch
wesentlich günstiger herzustellen wenn
man sie einfach in massen produziert
zukunftsvisionen bei denen jeder
haushalt mit seinem eigenen 3d drucker
alles druck was er für den alltag
benötigt halte ich persönlich für
unrealistisch schon gar nicht dass man
sich seine eigene pizza oder
lebensmittel ausdrücken wird wäre er
einfach umständlich da man die rohstoffe
für diese gegenstände ja trotzdem noch
nach hause geliefert bekommen muss und
wenn ich schon tomatensoße käse teig und
alles einzeln kaufen muss oder geliefert
bekomme da kann ich mir auch direkt die
fertige pizza nehmen oder interessanter
finde ich das schon die idee von amazon
paketwagen sollen in der zukunft nicht
mehr vom amazon lager zur haustür fahren
wenn man etwas bestellt sondern sie
fahren dauerhaft in der stadt umher und
an bord sind bestimmte rohmaterialien
und 3d drucker wenn man dann einen
auftrag erteilt beginnt der 3d drucker
zu drucken und der wagen fährt in
richtung kunde innerhalb von wenigen
stunden wird das gewünschte objekt an
vor die haustür geliefert
lohnen wird sich so was allerdings nur
für unternehmen die prototypen testen
oder präsentieren wollen
für uns normale kunden wird so ein
service einfach viel zu teuer sein
außerdem stellen weit verbreitete 3d
drucker auch einige fahrer viele von
euch wissen bestimmt dass man mit so
einem 3d drucker jetzt schon schuss
fähige pistole gedroht hat zwar halten
diese nicht mehr als 100 schuss durch
aber das kann ja auch schon mehr als
genug sein
pläne für tödliche waffen kann man sich
einfach so im internet herunterladen
was meint ihr wird die neue technik den
3d druck revolutioniert
und steht in der zukunft in jedem
haushalt einen 3d drucker oder bleibt
das ganze ein nischenprodukt für
unternehmen und die medizin
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr dazu zu
sagen habt meine heutige buchempfehlung
nexus was passiert wenn man seinen kopf
an das internet anschließen könnte eine
name droge macht es möglich sehr
spannendes hörbuch und das ganze gibt's
sogar gratis wenn ihr euch bei audible
einen account erstellt der link dazu
unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bis nächste woche